[Music]
this girl's life was cut brutally short
on a day which was also undoubtedly her
happiest
[Music]
sapi russos just eight years old in May
2017 was murdered as she was leaving the
Ariana Grande concert in Manchester the
attack's youngest victim she just
thought this horror about herself where
she could get anything she wanted just
by smiling she's just a she was just a
magnet to people they are happy memories
that will remain untouched but so will
the thought of knowing his daughter
suffered unimaginable pain
that little girl was let down 100 by the
Emergency Services they should be
ashamed of themselves that they allowed
that to happen
they should not allow a child to be
taken out on a cardboard
poster
that's full of blood from somebody else
and it's that what the second reports
from a public inquiry will address
focusing on the response of the
emergency services on the night of the
Manchester Arena attack
over months of evidence the inquiry
heard there were failings across the
board police Chiefs forced to apologize
the fire service embarrassed by their
response and paramedics criticized for
the delay in treating victims experts
revealed there were missed opportunities
to save lives including safies
it was at 10 31 PM Salman abadi
detonated his bomb in the foyer of the
Manchester Arena at 10 57 a piece of
advertising board was used as a
makeshift stretcher to carry Safi out of
the Arena by two police officers and a
member of the public she was carried 102
meters to an exit on Trinity way but
there were no ambulances in sight she
waited 17 minutes before an ambulance
was flagged down by a police officer to
take her to hospital at 11 40 Safi was
pronounced dead after losing too much
blood from her legs in her final moments
it was Paul Reed a poster seller who
stayed by Safi doing all he possibly
could to comfort her as they waited for
professional help
but like yes I was thinking in a minute
now everybody's gonna come in and
they're going to get me out and kick me
out of there but it just didn't didn't
work like that I do blame the top brass
for you know
um you know I'm not
dealing with situation probably
the Emergency Services say it is
inappropriate to comment before the
report is published on Thursday when
Five Years on families are victims like
Safi may feel they're closer to the
truth but they will want nothing less
than real changes into man Rashid Sky
News Manchester